almost 200 000 people have died from
covet 19 in the united states
no country has been hit as hard as the
u.s
and no country has politicized the
pandemic like america
either with no vaccine and no cure for
covid19
face masks provide the most effective
protection
and yet president trump refuses to wear
one
rejecting the advice from doctors and
scientists
listen to what the head of the centers
for disease control told a
congressional committee on wednesday
i'm not going to comment directly about
the president but i am going to comment
as the cdc
director that face mass these face men
are the most important powerful public
health tool we have i might even go so
far as to say that this face
mask is more guaranteed to protect
me against covid than when i take a
covet vaccine
because the immunogenicity may be 70
percent
and if i don't get an immune response
the vaccine's not going to protect me
this face mask will
that is the head of the cdc arguably the
world's most respected
infectious disease prevention center he
is speaking with the force of facts and
science but that is
easily overpowered by the politics of
protests in the u.s
consider florida nearly 13 000 people
have died there from the virus
despite evidence that masks prevent
infection and can even prevent
death some people in florida are adamant
anti-massacres
i want you to take a look at what
happened this week inside a
target store in fort lauderdale
what you're looking at is a flash mob of
anti-masters walking through the store
telling customers to take their masks
off the startled shoppers you see now
they're wearing their masks they are
protected
we hope but the protesters shouting
loudly in a non-socially distanced
group they are making themselves prime
targets for the virus they
know that but they don't believe it
here in berlin we have also seen
demonstrations of anti-massacres but on
this side of the atlantic
the virus itself remains threat number
one and that threat
is again acute the number of new
coronavirus cases in europe is surging
every country reporting spikes in new
infections some such as france
reporting more daily cases now than they
did at the peak back in april
the uk one of europe's hardest hit
countries
imposed stricter social restrictions
last week
and spain is expected to announce new
targeted lockdown measures for madrid
on friday madrid accounts for one-third
of all coronavirus cases
in spain and the country is registering
several
thousand new infections every day and
even here in germany where infections
and deaths have remained relatively low
we are seeing a sizable jump in new
cases
all of this has the world health
organization worried and
sounding the alarm in the spring and
early summer
we were able to see the impact of strict
lockdown measures
our efforts our sacrifices paid off
in june cases hit an all-time
low the september case numbers however
should serve as a wake-up call for all
of us all right
bring in now my colleague pablo foley
elias here at the big table
pablo i mean this is deja vu for us but
for the people
in madrid why is madrid in this
situation yet again
well first and foremost it comes down to
a lack of preparation with regards to uh
what's happening now in the in the
medical system there's a lack of staff
well they're more prepared in the sense
that they have
all the the masks and all those sort of
things that they didn't have back in
march
and april now they have a problem with
staff numbers so often it's very
difficult for people to actually even
get a test done because a lot of the
medical centers so the primary care
facilities are just
not able to cope with the nurses died
from covenants well this is it there are
a lot and they're also having a problem
in that they just haven't hired enough
staff they weren't prepared for it and
one big issue that was being discussed a
lot over the summer was the lack of
contact tracing
and people working in that area in
madrid and it was heavily criticized of
the regional government so this
combination of issues
has led the capital to the situation
that we find ourselves in
and how bad are the numbers the numbers
are not good you mentioned a few of them
there but actually with regards to the
tests
almost one in four of the tests coming
back are positive in madrid
that's incredibly high considering they
should be below five percent for a
situation to be considered
under control they're they account for
around a third of spain's total new
cases in madrid
now the hospitals are filling up it's
nowhere near the situation it was back
in march and april
but it is causing some concern and even
this field hospital which was quite
famous back back in the pandemic the
worst of it
um is potentially going to be opened up
so there's a lot of concern amongst the
residents there all right so the numbers
are not good who is most affected then
by these new infections well this is the
area which is uh causing obviously a lot
of controversy and if you look at the
regions or the parts of the city that
are most affected
it also happens to be the poorer parts
of the city in fact the numbers there
are
off the charts and in some instances
it's over a thousand cases per 100 000
when you compare that to germany which
is at 19
you can really see how bad the situation
is and within the city the richer parts
of the city are also around a third of
those figures
why because you've got high numbers of
people who are unemployed or working in
essentially precarious situations uh
often they can't take a day off if
they're ill
so they also can't get the primary care
that they need because the primary care
facilities in those areas are just
not able they can't socially distance
they can't socially distance because
they're living in poor conditions and so
this
is the problem it's a combination of
problems there also it's a city that is
very well connected it has a very good
um
commuter system very good metro trains
and buses so people move around with
frequency so it's it's you know
highlighting the fact that
if you're rich you won't be as badly
affected i mean
that's important to remember and it's
also important to remember that
you know all of europe is watching spain
right now to see if these
targeted local lockdowns will do the job
because
no one wants to have a second major
lockdown you're absolutely right and
we've already seen it in certain parts
of spain where some cities have actually
had localized lockdowns
but really what they want to avoid is
actually a lockdown like the one that we
saw back in march and april it causes a
lot of stress and panic
among spaniards i've lived in madrid for
many many years and i know
how people are feeling about that and i
know a lot of these stories first hand
of how difficult it is to get a test
done
so you know a combination of very
worrying yeah the worst
the worst deja vu that's for sure pablo
fuller elias pablo as always thank you
worldwide coronavirus infections have
passed 30 million that according to the
latest figures from
john hopkins university more than 940
000 people have now died of covet 19.
these numbers announced as israel heads
back into a nationwide coronavirus
lockdown later on friday it's the first
country to shut down for
a second time hundreds protesting the
return of the measures
in tel aviv saying another lockdown
would cause yet
more harm to the economy the three week
long restrictions
come into effect just hours before the
start of the jewish new year
rosh hashanah israeli authorities say
the measures are necessary after the
infection rates soared back
to become one of the highest in the
world our jerusalem correspondent tanya
kramer
has this report just a few hours before
the country goes into its second
prolonged lockdown
people in this market here in jerusalem
are rushing to get their shopping done
the lockdown comes at the start of one
of the most important holidays
rosh hashanah the jewish new year
starting friday israelis will only be
allowed to venture 500 metres from their
home
the final list of restrictions and
exemptions published on thursday islam
the new lockdown comes as the country
has seen infection rates rise
dramatically
the new rules will keep israelis at home
except for going out to cover basic
needs to go out for shopping or to go to
work
schools malls sports centers will be
shattered
and restaurants will only be allowed to
do deliveries
this follows weeks of erratic
decision-making by the government
its handling of the corona crisis has
been sharply criticized in recent weeks
i think it's going to be hard after one
lockdown i think
most people are just kind of tired of it
they see it as mainly political more
than a public health issue
and especially now with the whole days
it seems that you know just
a lot more people are not going to
not going to follow the rules
everybody is enraged and there's a sense
of confusion
i feel it is a mistake it wasn't well
prepared there was no exit strategy
from the last lockdown and now we enter
another cycle of horror
i think it's unnecessary mostly because
there are a lot of loopholes not to keep
it
i don't know if my daughter will be
allowed to work or my husband
i don't know what's open and what is not
for now the lockdown is expected to last
at least
three weeks leaving israelis worried
that the country could be in for an
extended
lockdown period well germany's top
virologist has warned
that this country could be facing a
further rise in new coronavirus cases
and see a possible return
to tighter restrictions christian dawson
regularly briefs the german government
and developed the first covet diagnostic
test
which was adopted by the world health
organization in recent days
new infections in germany have risen
again to levels
not seen since april
wear a mask wash your hands and maintain
distance
people in germany are accustomed to
following these safety and hygiene
guidelines
yet despite this the rate of infection
is climbing with more than 2 000 new
cases in a single day
the highest count since april
germany's most prominent virologist
christian drosten
sees the development critically he spoke
at a conference in berlin on thursday
and detailed some of his concerns in an
interview with deutsche welle
and look at other countries look at
france the uk
spain what we're seeing there is what we
will see in germany
if we don't react very early on
in in a way that needs to be adjusted
that needs to be let's say
bearable for the economy and at the same
time
targeted and this is a very difficult
task to find the right point of time
charleston has praise for germany's
coronavirus policies
and the response by the country's
leadership to the pandemic
he says germany has been efficient and
measures have softened the pandemic's
impact
but he also says the government could do
a better job of explaining why certain
decisions are made
it is not sufficient to impose rules
that people don't understand and so the
cooperation of the population
especially in the coming weeks and
months
over over ottoman and winter
is probably one of the most important
functions in
the whole concept to to intervene
charleston says from a global
perspective current developments in
india are particularly worrying
the virus is spreading there almost
uncontrollably and he says the situation
in many western countries could also
become more threatening
there are areas including in europe
where there is little control where
countries already go into autumn
with a high background incidence
i i believe there are countries
including
in europe that will have to
impose stricter measures very soon
drawston like many others is hoping a
vaccine will soon be available
he sees it as the only clear way out of
the global state of crisis
let's take a look now at some more
developments in the pandemic the world
health organization says more than 170
countries have signed up for its
global vaccine plan countries have until
midnight friday to make legally binding
commitments to that program a number of
latin american nations
have asked for an extension india has
reported more than
96 000 new cases of covet 19 in the last
24 hours
the country's health ministry says that
over a thousand more people
had died as the infection rate shows no
sign of slowing
and australia has reported its lowest
total of new cases in three months
35 new cases reported on friday the bulk
of them
in the state of victoria
you